hey everyone you're watching a breakout
from the gamespot after dark podcast in
which we discuss
the new steam deck which is valve's
portable gaming pc
is it any good who knows is it going to
replace a
switch listen to us and find out and
more importantly will it fit into your
gaming life
that's a question for you to answer if
you enjoy this make sure to subscribe to
the gamespot after dark podcast where we
go through plenty more topics and have a
whole lot of banter
it's good fun stuff wholesome check it
out
steam valve releasing a portable gaming
pc
that's just wild so steam has announced
something called
the steam deck not to be confused with
the elgato stream deck
um i literally thought that's what you
were talking
i've already seen multiple people tweet
a picture of an elgato stream deck with
the we
uh we switch uh joy cons tape
that's pretty good okay but yeah this
this is a portable
uh gaming pc um it's
a decent specs um we can rattle off like
some
basic stuff uh specifically
they work the valve worked with amd to
create a custom apu
it's got zentu rdna two it's got a seven
inch touchscreen with capacitive
multi-touch it's got
track pads for precision um it's got a
gyro if you want to do some of that
motion controlled gaming
um relatively powerful certainly seems
to be the most powerful
portable gaming device that currently
exists
um rap to the oled
switch didn't last very long they
announced this
on the day that the pre-orders open for
um
but yeah it's uh it's an lcd screen
um optically bonded lcd is that is that
just an old led
no that's not one no no that's not what
i think only bonded
they put they put an a word with o in
there to debate us
you know it you know it uh 60 hertz but
yeah so
basically you can download games to it
it's not specifically just a
a kind of a repackaging of their cloud
service
um and it looks very much like a switch
they call it an all-in-one portable
gaming pc
and you can also do things like uh
run standard applications off of it and
you can plug it into
a monitor and use it as a pc if you
wanted to do that for some reason um so
yeah
there's a couple of models that are
going to be coming out for it um
i'm looking at uh the i was looking at i
was looking at the website is an
absolute catastrophe for this thing
[Laughter]
but they've got three like every time
you try and find out what it is it's
like hey look at this instead you know
all right man please chill
uh there's three options there's a 349
i'm gonna say this in pounds because um
i'm i'm in the uk and it will not show
me anything
there's something around 300 there's
something around 450 and a
570 um and the the cheapest one is got
64
um gigabytes of internal storage then it
goes up to 256 with
nvme ssd internals and then 512
and then the most expensive models 512
it's got premium
anti-glare etched glass a carrying case
and
a bunch of virtual keyboard themes and
some [ __ ] like that but
um it seems
yeah interesting michael you up for this
uh let me see so i
am uh ex-tech expert uh over here at
gamespot and
i'll look at it you said the base model
of 64 gigabytes internal memory
you ain't installing [ __ ] on that thing
yeah you can expand it with microsd
oh okay cool okay so that's what's up
yeah uh that's cool but that's
obviously not going to be top tier
gaming as if you have an
nvme ssd which is pretty like i wouldn't
say standard but i think most
like mid to high-end gaming pcs have
some sort of ssd
uh running most of their applications um
this is this is this is fascinating
especially for you know when i think
about gaming pcs
uh and if i haven't looked at the specs
like the exact specs yet but if it has
like the the
those amd apu's which are actually
pretty pretty damn good
um like those aren't bad prices for for
what gaming pcs costs relatively and the
fact that you're getting like all of
that
in like an all-in-one package um that
seems
that seems uh kind of competitive at
least i saw the
alienware prototype for what they had as
a handheld gaming pc as well
like the idea was cool like actually
holding that thing and playing something
was cool but i don't think the the
technology wasn't necessarily there
for uh for it to handle yeah
like pc gaming at that at that level so
um
but you know steam steam knows i guess
they kind of know what they're doing
they've had failed hardware things like
they've had the the steam machines
before that kind of
you know they're supposed to be like a
consolized version of a pc and then they
had
the steam link which is actually like
functionally a cool thing i know
jean-luc here
uh you had we're talking about the steam
link and how you know people who still
use that thing and then like
question-wise that was pretty cool but
that's been discontinued because
i mean oh the fervor kind of ran out uh
with that so maybe this is like another
i they don't have like a strong history
with hardware i know the steam
controller was also like
ah this thing isn't this this ain't it
chief um
so it's taking another stab at it a
valve index you know i'll give credit
credits of
the the index because that's the best vr
headset in the game that's just wild
expensive though
um but i don't know i i want to i want
to see the steam deck i want to like
actually see it functioning and see how
games run on that thing
um the power is there but you're not i
mean you're not necessarily going to be
running things in 4k
high frame rates whatever uh i mean
you can get like 1080p 60fps on several
games with uh if the
if the apu is powerful enough so uh i
don't know
this could be this could be a cool thing
yeah there's some really interesting
kind of like
things that they have put in there like
they've got they've built in a suspend
resume feature into
steam os for it um and the the um
like it works with most like is it's
bluetooth ready and it's got a usbc port
so they've got an image of like the
thing on a on a
um on a table with two arcade sticks
hooked up to it and yeah they're just
playing a fighting game
and then the other the thing that we
kind of like touched on earlier like it
can be plugged into a monitor or a tv in
the same way that you would with a
with a nintendo switch and um it plugs
in via usbc port and
that can carry um video and audio
um and peripherals and that kind of
stuff so it it's
really interesting but mike it's such a
weird thing
like it i don't know where it fits in
like i can't find a
a a hole in my current gaming life where
i would
fit that in um especially given that
i've been recently checking out xcloud
and it works
so well um and like i'm trying to figure
out what is the use case for this like
evan
like is this something that you are
interested in like do you
can you think of a use case where it
would work for you
no i'm not personally interested in this
i think like the switch
already kind of fulfills that like
portable gaming gap and for me
i would go to the switch first because i
like nintendo's first party games
i guess this is cool can you can you
like download
games for offline play and like play
them offline or do you have to be
connected yeah
it seems that way it seems that you can
just download to the hard drive and play
as is
right so in that case like yeah i guess
there's tons of games on steam
that like for example are not on a
switch and if you want to be able to
play those portably in an easily
accessible way
absolutely this might be a good option
for you but i imagine people that are
dedicated to steam that have that full
steam library
already have the pc set up for that
might already own a nintendo switch to
play the games they want to play
portably um i'm not sure but
i also think it's funny that they
announced this today the day the switch
oled pre-orders go live just to hit
nintendo in the jugular like no hey wait
up before you pre-order that
maybe you want to buy this instead but
yeah for me personally no this is not
something that i'm interested in i'm
i'm oh should go oh hi
i'm i'm looking at i'm like the more i
look at it the more i'm like i wanna i
wanna try this thing i want to see yeah
this is the thing i want to try
yeah because i'm looking at the steam
deck website and like i'm looking at the
specs too like the
uh like 16 gigabytes of ram uh
and then like the rdna uh like it's it's
it's not the most powerful thing
obviously but it's powerful enough to
run games at 1080p
uh maybe medium settings and getting
like higher than 30 fps i would imagine
so like
i can play something like control or
doom only on on a portable device that's
that this thing is
clearly stronger than a switch too it
kind of has to be
um now what i'm thinking about is
battery life though like
oh yeah because yeah if as long like the
the switch battery is decent for what it
is but
this is packing a lot more a much bigger
punch
uh so i don't know ign has a hands-on
with it
and i think based on that people people
have been like tweeting at me saying
like it's eight
eight hours eight to ten hours i'm not
sure i'm really
correct but um like there seems to be
some sort of like
how we'll see about that kind of depends
on the game
towards that yeah like if you're running
a super high-end game it'll probably
just
drain it i should add that the screen
resolution
is 800p so it's 18 12 18
1280 by 800 so you won't have to stress
the thing to run a game at even 1080p
right i'm sure
so the switch is at 720p it looks fine
yeah so i'm 800 uh like
1280x800 that it'll look a little bit
better
uh in terms of like fine resolution but
you will you'll have access to things
like anti-aliasing
uh and better frame rates so i mean the
experience would be
like if you're comparing this to a
switch it's probably going to be like a
lot better
of a visual experience but it's not
going to be like the super high end it's
not like you're going to be playing
like phones have higher resolutions than
this but obviously phones aren't going
to play games like control
so there's these i don't know there's
expectations like set your expectations
yeah i'm kind of where you guys are i'm
i definitely want to just like i don't
know if i'm going to
i want to show all that money but i want
to i want to play it i want to know what
it's like i want to
i think that the most potentially
interesting thing where
i can see this going um would be just
sort of
the open-endedness of it the fact that
you can like run
uh like an operating system on it like i
people are gonna like
hella mod this [ __ ] out emulators on it
like people are gonna go wild with that
i was gonna say that like an open-ended
switch where you can just be like i'm
going to put whatever i want on it
you want the real virtual console yeah
there you go
no you could you could uh you could take
technically you could run switch games
on it if you wanted i mean
i don't know nothing about that uh evan
evan's gonna write you out if you're not
careful
i think the one thing i'm a little
cautious about
is uh how like the controls feel just
because like
dude man that that um that steam
controller
not great not a fan of that um and i
mean
it's looking just obviously like i
haven't touched it and i would assume
they've improved their text since then
but like
looking at it it very much is in line
with
sort of that it's got the track pad
which makes sense because you know
you got to give an option for kind of
mouse and keyboard games but
i'm a little like i don't know i didn't
love the way that
thing felt so like valve hasn't proved
to me that they can make a controller
that i'm like into playing
i look at that like where that d-pad is
it's like right to the left of the
stick and i'm like that doesn't seem
that
great everything feels really pushed
into the corners yeah
i'm i'm really not sure how that's gonna
how that's gonna feel
people are people people are already
pointing out that the b button looks
like it's trying to get away from the
rest of them
yeah your finger is gonna like slip off
the edge trying to
trying to tap it yeah it's it's got
massive game gear energy
and yeah it's slightly worrying to me
like i don't
like i don't like where those buttons
are placed at all and if
it seems like i mean heim you can
correct me like it seems like it's going
to be relatively heavy
like based on the yeah that thing will
nothing looks chunky
yeah like there's a there's a ladder
there's a video of a lad playing
out his biceps are being engaged in that
video
so i'm like yeah i'm i'm looking at i'm
looking at like their kind of uh gif
or video on the site of playing uh jedi
jedi fallen order
that what i will say is that at least
from what i'm seeing uh that the
the analog sticks look nice though
that's the important thing because i
hate the joy-con analog sticks
i will never play a game that needs
precise camera control
on a switch joy cons yeah uh but this
one looks like
i mean i would expect you know after the
valve index and how good
those controllers are i imagine that you
know
valve has learned a lot from that and i
could see
some of that being that some of that
that um that kind of being integrated
into how this thing is designed but
again like
this thing look like look chunky because
you remember that that's a seven inch
screen on that thing then
uh the ways in which the that controller
protrudes out or like the rest of it
kind of
is built around that seven inch screen
like oh boy
that is hefty it's weird that it's got
such a huge bezel on it considering that
was like the big thing people didn't
like about the switch and then like the
oled like got rid of it it's kind of
it it's a minor thing but i'm just like
oh man like
like yeah i think inevitably i'm gonna
end up
probably getting one of these just to
try it and like
um and like have it there because we all
have problems in that way where we see a
new game
and we're like we gotta buy that [ __ ] um
but i will say like that has this has
dissuaded me from buying a
uh switch oh led because now i'm like if
i can spend a decent chunk of that led
money on a brand new device
i'll do that instead and i do want to
like the idea like i'm thinking about
use cases and there's
a whole bunch of people who probably
want to play pc games that
can't lug around a a kind of you know
massive
uh rig that probably will look i'm
looking at this again that's great and
or people who like oh you know i'm gonna
grab this and take my xbox controller
and connect it via bluetooth and just
you know when i'm out at a hotel or at a
friend's house i can still play
a pc game um i am interested to see if
like what happens when you like
plug in a a webcam to it and
download obs and see what happens like
what kind of like
streaming [ __ ] you could be your
streaming pc
yeah that could that could be like a
really cute like streaming pc like do
like irl streams off of it
yeah yeah yeah so like that's something
i would like to test
i do want to like see if we can log in
and write a new story on it
let's see what happens but yeah i
i it's just the the thing that i keep
coming back to is like
uh we're in a like many of us are in a
kind of position where we're trying
we're moving towards lightening the load
and you know using cloud functionality
to make uh
gaming's easier the footprint of
portable gaming
lighter so then this this big old beefy
boy comes along and it's like hello i'm
here i'm the juggernaut
um so we'll see how that goes down but i
definitely am interested in checking it
out
yes um it's interesting too
like this wasn't an e3 this could have
been a big e3 thing if they wanted it
um but instead they decided to do it on
their own terms like most companies
don't care valve balcony thousand five
is like
three oh my hormones hate e3
uh but yeah we'll see how it goes i'm
definitely
work there's gonna be a lot of
interesting written and video features
coming out of that so make sure you keep
your eye on gamescore.com in the
immediate future